what i need to know is where did covet
come from
did it get released was it in a lab was
it a bad virus
i just 20 20 just tell me well first
first first of all
we don't know and that's one of the
biggest issues when people make
assertions like it did this it did that
the general thinking is that
it emerged from bats and then because of
the unsanitary conditions of the wet
markets in china
you end up with it spreading around and
then going crazy
and that's really easy to believe man i
don't understand why people like
can't believe that i know tucker carlson
had that woman on sure
so i'm for those of you that are
listening a woman who worked at
i believe hong kong university or
university in hong kong saying that it
was manufactured and released on purpose
and i'm kind of like
first it's one person who didn't work in
any of these labs in china saying this
and i'm i feel like there's certain she
says she has evidence
she released a paper on it yeah
explaining it and so i can respect that
for sure i'm not i'm not a scientist i'm
not going to refute it
i'm just saying it's it's really easy to
believe
that the horrifying human rights abuses
and unsanitary conditions of china and
their pollution problems
it i'm sure they got all kinds of crazy
diseases man like you go there and you
walk out with like 17 new plagues or
something
and i'm trying to be mean i'm saying
right right those those wet markets are
really dirty yeah they don't really
exist in the united states do they not
not in the same way but if you go to
like chinatown you they you you've seen
this right when you're in new york and
they have all like the dead
like the fish and the rabbits and stuff
that's like sitting in front of the
shops
uh fish yeah i don't think i've ever
seen they they hang from the windows but
yeah you've not seen the rabbits
i don't think so i'm pretty sure maybe
it's ducks maybe i'm thinking ducks
definitely
okay yeah ducks duck sucks i've pretty
sure i've seen like maybe
maybe i haven't seen rabbits maybe i've
dreamt that it's not real
i don't know but it's not the same maybe
in the walking dead
yeah yeah but uh when you go to
uh it's i wouldn't call it a wet market
they have like a display of all the fish
and it kind of smells well yeah but
that's but that's anywhere that's
that's yeah no for sure any seafood
market in the city
you know yeah but but yeah i mean
there's definitely i think there's it's
probably regulated a little bit more
there's probably
it's probably a lot more sanitary than
in china i would i would
think i'm guessing i've never been to
china
are you guys familiar with putrescine
and cadaverine no what are they they're
two
chemicals that basically digest meat and
they break it down and they make
the putrid cadavers yeah
is that what it's called this is crazy
that that stuff's real no it's not like
mainstream
known to people but yeah gross i don't
believe you check it out
and cadaverine no way totally is that is
that real i look it up it does sound
right though
really that's what makes that's that
black rock on the draw
yeah let me let me go how did where
where are we going with this
we were talking we were talking about
the wet markets and then we talked about
it okay i'm like
chinatown but here here's here's a thing
that
that joe biden mentions all the time
he's like
why didn't we have people on the ground
in china when
you know like why didn't why didn't we
send people there it's like do you think
they would have showed us
really yeah what would we have found i
don't think we would have found anything
they bring us to their potemkin wet
markets where everyone's wearing like a
chef
suit and they're like doing song and
dance and like all everything's in a
refrigerator do you think they would
have taken us to like
if we would have said okay wet market
maybe maybe it happened here um
but you got that lab down the street too
yeah i know so
can we check that out do you think do
you think they would have said
uh right this way sir you know like i
don't i think
so no i do i do but they would be like
right this way and then they would like
walk people and then they would come to
this
like hole they would look like a door
yeah and then when they walk through it
two guys are holding up a painting yes
of like and then they run away and it's
actually a pub
you know so they tricked the people into
thinking they're walking in the lab and
then like inside
it's a bunch of actors i'm half kidding
but i think they would have been like oh
yes we'll show you the lab and it's
already been purged of everything
just like right yeah they trash every
time yeah exactly didn't they just
supposedly destroy evidence in any way
didn't they destroy papers i don't know
for sure but i know there was like major
flooding
sweeping the area and people were
worried it was gonna it was like
i think the flooding was hitting wuhan
was it or yeah so the other thing
interesting that's been happening is
that um
they've had a lot of explosions there in
what yeah they have i've read multiple
instances of
gigantic explosions and i don't haven't
pulled up for anything
but yeah that was really interesting to
me that's uh what's going on over there
i wow yeah weird right coincidental i
i know you're shocked yeah it's shocking
it's crazy weird stuff happens in china
what if
you know uh who are we talking to they
said was it jack murphy said we're at
war with china yeah it's just fourth
generational warfare
so one of them is one of the problems a
lot of people have is like a normalcy
bias
and an optimism bias and so they'll
assume
um i guess this is another kind of bias
forward i don't know which one would be
like a history bias
if it doesn't happen this way it's not
really happening you know what i mean
like they assume war means like you know
fighter jets
are shooting each other in the sky and
blowing up and then like we land a bunch
of u-boats on the shores of china
and like ah and stormin but that's not
what warfare is today today it's
manipulation it's it's it's media
strategy
it's disruption it's it's demoralization
and so i wonder if some of the things
that are happening
in the us and china and i'm not i'm not
i'm not i'm not saying that there's a
grand conspiracy or anything i'm saying
there could be warfare going on we don't
know about
so it's it's actually there's something
called industrial control systems
they're
you know digital technology that can
control power plants
and refineries these things are easily
hacked and
easily disrupted i went and i went and
saw tons of displays i was at uh um
defcon and black at this hacker
conventions years ago
and they had a whole section on ics
hacking industrial control systems and
they're like
here's how you can blow up a power plant
and they actually did a demonstration
where they made a pipe burst
they put a valve on it though so that
when it bursts it pressurizes the valve
but there was like one one thing where
they said like this system that we're
manipulating
is what nuclear power plants use it's
what refineries use
and we can actually hack this system
very easily with only a few lines of
code to send
what of the fluid whichever it is in the
same direction into the same pipe until
it
explodes and the pressure boom will
spray fuel and probably spark a fire
and then uh and go up and so i think
about stuff like that
and i don't know to what extent we've
shown up our cyber security defenses
but i don't think i don't i don't know
that even if we did
it would make a difference all right so
i bring this up because then you hear
all these stories about like you know
this oil refinery blew up for unknown it
was an accident it must been an accident
then you hear about these explosions
happening in wuhan you hear about all
these things and i wonder how much of
this
may actually be hot war like legit
full-on efforts by both countries
to to hurt each other meanwhile the
public just thinks everything's okay
or maybe it was the chinese
uh trying to cover up things and oh my
god this explosion just happened
for no reason so i mean i i mean it's
possible i
as far as as far as infiltrating these
systems
do you think it that all countries
have the potential of doing it to all
other countries dude the scary thing
about
cyber war is that some 19 year old kid
who's bored
in his bedroom from like anywhere could
be like i would like to do these things
twitter yeah so uh like when twitter got
hacked
there was uh the associated press got
hacked and they they tweeted that they
were hacked
right yeah oh no from from the kid yeah
that's right
yeah well so this was but it was an
inside job right no no no
no i'm talking about a different
scenario oh okay so this was years ago
uh this kid in russia
he was uh syrian hacked twitter
and we we believe this is the guy at
least you know the last time i
had anything to do with reporting on the
story uh he was just some college kid
i believe he was in moscow and he
tweeted that
obama had been injured in an attack on
the white house and it caused a stock
drop off of like four point something
billion dollars
and then within five minutes once it was
realized it was fake it rebounded
what people don't realize is that was a
dramatic and massive transfer of wealth
in only a few minutes
when the stock got sold off because of
the cyber attack
that was person a selling and losing the
asset
and then when it rebounded went right
back up that was person b
get it different people were getting rid
of
i couldn't imagine being that person who
is sitting on your stock
then there's this fake tweet the
computer automatically sells off your
assets
and then someone else automatically
bought them right back up and then you
realize it was all fake
okay because uh the they they had a they
said you know they had like a sell limit
you know like if it drops below this
then automatically sell it off is that
here
yeah so happened so what happened was
when a few people heard this and sold
then they hit their afro it's called i'm
not a stock person yeah money either
they hit that number where it's like if
it drops this low sell
which triggered a cascade and then once
people realized it was fake people
started buying again which triggered the
other cascading in the direction
so we saw billions of dollars exchange
hands at that point that's
crazy yeah so that's that's the scary
kind of stuff you know we could see
so i think i think maybe it's it's all
speculative for sure
but yeah it could be them trying to
cover things up and i think the craziest
thing about it is sort of the
complacency is that the right word you
know like the the uh
collusion in a sense from media
companies
and from social media so uh
for example what i mean is when tucker
carlson has a woman on
who says i've written a paper and i have
evidence that this was made in the lab
i say prove it i don't care i don't i
get it you're a professor
prove it instagram blocked it saying it
was fake news
why and the the links were you know so
when facebook or instagram says it's
fake news you can click and say see why
the stories had nothing to do with
tucker carlson or his his whistleblower
right it had
it um if if i remember correctly uh
tucker said that
that some of the examples were written
well before
the paper was published so that's
i know yeah it's it's uh i noticed
something really interesting
it's scary how they can control these
things but why
is it that way because i don't think
there's a grand you know architect
controlling the machine
but when tucker carlson has an expert
with credentials phd from a university
in hong kong who says they have proof
and published a paper on it
how is that fake news it's an expert
opinion but somebody did come out
somebody somebody did uh they saw that
tweet
and said like they they hit a button to
exactly to market that was not an
automatic thing exactly
so because you because an algorithm
can't tell right what the context of a
discussion with tucker carlson is
exactly thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you